We talked a little bit about sugar.
You've mentioned it.
I think most people
would say yeah, it's bad. Do they really
know how bad it is? It's one of the
biggest misconceptions in the world and
just last night
on my online membership service. I have
an online membership service you can get
a subscription for.
And part of the subscription gives you 3
hours of live health webinars a week. We
do 3 hours of live health webinars a
week for subscribers.
And
I have over 100 hours of archived health
webinars that are available in the
library that are available to members at
my website. Just last night I did a
1-hour presentation all about sugar.
And sugar metabolism. Because it is an
extremely misunderstood concept.
Extremely misunderstood. So,
if if I can pitch myself here I'll give
you the short answer about sugar, but if
the listening audience really wants to
see this in depth, then just go to
drglidden.com.
Become a subscriber. It's $20 a month.
You can cancel at any time.
And check out the webinars that I've
done. Because knowledge is power. So,
the problem with sugar
is not the sugar.
The problem with sugar is how much sugar
and how well is your body equipped to
metabolize it.
Sugar is the gasoline of your body.
You could not blink an eyelash without
sugar. Your body loves and needs sugar.
You know how much?
DNA
your genetic material
deoxyribo
nucleic acid.
The ribo stands for ribose which is a
sugar.
Your DNA
is made from sugar.
So, how bad can it be?
You couldn't exist. Your physical body
would not exist if there wasn't sugar.
Your body loves and needs sugar. Sugar
is so important to your body, your liver
can make it. Through a process called
gluconeogenesis. Just like it can make
cholesterol. Cuz it needs it. It's very
important. Sugar is very important.
Sugar is not the Antichrist. You'd be
dead without sugar. You wouldn't even be
existing without sugar.
The problem isn't sugar.
The problem is how much sugar are you
pouring down the hatch at any moment in
time?
And how well equipped is your body to
metabolize it?
Now,
if you look at a chart for the amount of
sugar that we were eating in the 1800s
and the amount of sugar that we were
eating now, it's like, oh my god, I
can't believe it. It's massive amounts
of sugar now, right?
And as I spoke about before, one of the
reasons for that is the food is so
anemic now because it's grown in soil
that's completely mineraly deprived. The
food tastes like crap. And so the food
industry puts sugar in with the food
just to make it taste good. All right?
So,
we've we are consuming culturally way
too much sugar, number one. And number
two,
in order for your body to process sugar
I remember sugar's like gasoline.
And all of the cells in your body,
trillions of cells in your body are like
little automobiles.
And they all need gasoline.
Sugar has to get inside the tank of all
of the cells of your body.
It does that through the use of insulin.
All right?
So, you eat something that has sugar in
it. Now there's sugar in your
bloodstream. Doesn't matter if it's
fructose, glucose, sucrose, doesn't
matter. Glucose is the preferred form of
sugar, but your body will take whatever
it can get. So, you've got sugar in your
blood.
When there's sugar in the blood, the
pancreas secretes insulin.
Now there's insulin and sugar in the
blood.
Insulin flows through the bloodstream
and through some agency that is
inexplicable that medical science is
clueless about.
Insulin sticks to and binds to insulin
receptors on the outside of every cell
wall.
It's kind of like somebody showing up to
your front door and ringing the
doorbell.
Right? And when they ring the doorbell
the kitchen door automatically opens
to allow the groceries to come in.
So, insulin binds to an insulin receptor
on the cell wall
sends a signal through the inside of the
cell to open up a sugar door
to allow the sugar into the cell and
that's how the fuel of sugar, the
gasoline of the body gets into the cell.
Insulin rings the bell, the kitchen door
opens and the groceries come in. In this
case, the sugar comes in. Life is good.
In order
for that signal from the front door to
get to the kitchen door
to open it
vanadium and chromium, which are two
peculiar trace minerals and a number of
other nutrients need to be present
inside the cell.
If they are not there
insulin rings the bell
the signal gets interrupted, the kitchen
door stays closed.
So, sugar piles up in the blood.
What does the body do? Makes more
insulin.
Sugar piles up in the blood. What does
the body do? Make more insulin.
It's called insulin resistance syndrome.
It's the same thing. Syndrome X,
metabolic syndrome, insulin resistance
syndrome, uh pre-type 2 diabetes and
type 2 diabetes from our point of view
are all the same illness.
Just more and more and more and more and
more and more of it. And what causes the
illness? Lack of minerals.
1957,
an MD Walter Mertz
proved
with scientific studies with mice
that if you eliminate chromium from the
diet of the mouse, the mouse gets type 2
diabetes.
You put chromium back, it goes away.
Further studies were done with the trace
mineral vanadium that showed the same
thing.
Now, remember your medical doctor is not
concerned with what causes disease.
Your medical doctor has no respect, no
appreciation, no training in medical
nutrition.
So, your medical doctor, when you were
having a blood sugar issue, which is on
the rise here.
Unbelievable. Skyrocketing.
The only thing your medical doctor will
advise you to do is wait until it gets
really bad
and then we'll give you metformin.
Oh, by the way, we have no idea how
metformin works.
The molecular action of metformin is
unknown.
Oh, what does it do, doctor? Well, it
does a number of things. The two biggest
are it reduces your liver's production
of glucose
and it reduces the absorption of glucose
by your intestinal tract. That's all
that it does.
Does that fix the doorway problem? No.
And then when it gets really bad, what
does the medical doctor do? Give you
more insulin.
Now, when insulin piles up in the
bloodstream in enormous amounts
by sheer volumetric pressure
it punches holes in the wall of the cell
wall.
And the cell dies.
Is that a good thing or a bad thing?
That's a bad thing.
This is why we believe
people with blood sugar issues
get peripheral neuropathy, gangrene,
lose their toes, lose their feet, lose
their fingers, lose their hands, lose
their legs, lose their arms.
It's the insulin.
We believe.
You know, in concert with excited
amounts of sugar. But nonetheless, the
MDs are clueless about how to fix this.
And they don't even care about how to
fix it.
We advise people
who are dealing with the blood sugar
issue to support and promote your body's
ability to optimize its blood sugar
metabolism. And we do that with mineral
supplementation and it's awesome.